[Music]
plenty of great quarterbacks in this
draft class and the market keeps
changing march 29 trey lance the
favorite to be the third overall pick
then mac jones prohibited favorite as of
april eight now
justin fields minus 110. so
sims you're the one that drove the
needle
to mac jones being minus 200. oh okay i
don't know and i don't know what caused
fields to be i was it just his pro day
workout pro day workout and there wasn't
one of those throws that made kyle
shanahan
have that larry david moment where you
cue the curb your enthusiasm theme song
with the overthrow but ohio state was
very selective about what was allowed to
be seen coming out of the justin fields
pro day but i think it was the reaction
that pro day that caused people to push
fields back up to the top of the stack
from a betting standpoint i mean i it
seems to be it seems to be that you know
the fact that shanahan was there for
that workout the fact that people think
because shanahan and justin fields were
at a camp together four years ago that
that means something there that way so
uh yeah i mean
again it's gonna be interesting to see
where this all goes it really is uh you
know where my money still is at this
point but it's it's fun to watch kind of
the markets flip and the conversation go
and there's a lot of heated
conversations over this number three
pick right now in sports media that's
for sure
what we're going to do for now we're
going to take the name of the
quarterback and match him with the team
regardless of draft we're not going to
try to crack the code on how the names
come off the board just right now gut
feeling justin fields where do you think
he ends up which team like i'm i'm i'm
really in a like tough spot here i i
don't know i i don't like i don't think
it's going to happen
at number three as you as you know i
don't think it's gonna happen at number
four with atlanta
right i look at that i i don't know in
my heart of hearts i don't see denver
going quarterback at number nine
i just don't i feel like man it's vic
fangios he want to deal with a rookie
quarterback situation i mean he's gonna
get fired if they do that this year
that's over so i don't look at it that
way okay so like i know i'm i'm supposed
to give you a quick answer here but i'm
kind of flushing this out i mean then i
start to think about all right new
england at 15
you know washington at 19. the steelers
are 24
you know and of course these teams can
move up you know
for a trade at some point or do that i
feel like he's not a new england guy
that's just how i feel there
will washington really take another ohio
state quarterback after the dwayne
haskins conversation do you think they
would do that i don't know
i for for my heart of hearts i want to
say pittsburgh he ends up in pittsburgh
makes a play to move up a little bit and
then that justin fields that's what i'm
saying now if if pittsburgh loves him
yeah okay they'll go get him because
they have traded up for guys they love
right troy palamolo centennial holmes
devin bush they trade up to get the guys
they love so if they really do love him
i don't rule that out i i think it's
simpler than that yeah i think i think
you're missing the obvious one and this
is a little bit of psychoanalysis on my
part but
i firmly believe
i firmly believe detroit is going to
take him okay because number one number
one chris spielman whatever his specific
title is
assistant to the traveling secretary
special adviser to the owner i'm not
quite sure what it is but i know he's
got a lot of juice
and he's got a strong personality he's
and now so does dan campbell and
remember the true sign of an alpha is to
know when to back down and concede and
know that another alpha has made the
decision but
i think the ohio state connection i
think spielman's going to be privy to
more information about fields than the
rest of us and it's going to be good
information about justin fields and i
also think spielman
he's not going to admit it yeah jared
goff
this guy not my kind of guy and i think
jared goff is a a band-aid
that they took on the contract they're
spending the money they picked up an
extra first-round draft pick to get him
let's not forget that two ones and a
three
to take on jared goff and to give up
matthew stafford i think they're looking
for their future and i think it's going
to be very difficult if fields is there
at seven for spielman to say no that's
where i think he's going to go at the
line well that's i mean it's a
possibility you lay it out the right way
i mean you you do
um
i i'm really interested to see if they
do go that route kind of like what
you're talking about you know to make
that move for jared goff yeah the money
they're gonna be paying them i
understand that you know the rams uh
took some of that burden but i know this
is one of those where i'm not sure where
detroit goes there i'm really not sure
where they go with this conversation so
i i do i look at that and i don't know
where justin fields ends up either i
really don't i think it's going to be
really interesting and i think that's
where there could be some major play
here in the first round because what if
a guy like him is on the board uh but
all right you say lions i'm saying
steelers later on in the round
all right mac jones do we need
any time can we can we bank our time
from this one i know what we're both
going to say yeah i'm going mac jones
there's no doubt about it you're going
49ers i'm going 49ers mac jones without
a doubt a hundred percent i haven't
changed my thought of that at all
definitely not listen i i feel in like
my heart of hearts
you know yeah of course i feel like it's
mac jones from the history of knowing my
friend you know from the simple fact
that
i i don't think you trade up that far in
the draft to go after two guys who yeah
have a lot of talent and trey lance and
justin fields but there's definitely
some major questions about them too like
they're real
and to me mac jones is
kind of like a ready to go proven
commodity and fits i think the mold of
what shanahan wants at the quarterback
position so yes i think mac jones 49ers
all the way
i don't think that kyle shanahan makes a
decisive move a month before the draft
unless he knows damn well who he writes
right i think back to 2006 when mike
shanahan traded up to get jay cutler
during the draft while the pick was on
the clock
that that is just both hilarious and
disturbing it is but but i but but
that's what he had to do to get cutler
you don't move to that spot ahead of
time because there's no guarantee the
board's going to fall your way kyle
doesn't have to worry about how the
board's going to fall he knows how the
board's gonna fall lawrence wilson one
two yeah the guy i want i'm going up to
get he didn't go up to get the third
overall pick so he could spend the next
next month saying oh i got the third
overall pick hey what am i gonna do
we'll figure that out later you don't
give up three ones and a three
to go up for well we'll evaluate the
three guys who are up there now and pick
the best one no you already know before
you make the move there's no way you
make that move without knowing chris no
agreed like i don't think you make that
move unless you're you know basically 95
98 like positive that's what you want to
do you know i do yeah okay yeah i i like
this guy i'm gonna do this i'm gonna
continue to do my homework on the other
guys because you know there's some like
big time talent traits there there's no
doubt about that do my homework do my
due diligence but i would think yes you
don't make that move unless you got your
eye on somebody to go wait that that's
the guy i want i want to make it for
that guy yeah you might like the whole
group as a whole okay i understand that
that gives you a little cushion but i
would think one guy was in mind when it
came to making that trade and that's
where yeah i still go to mac jones and
you know where where people got to
bought back like mac jones i understand
people think like
you know hey
face level to face level justin fields
yeah he's an adonis mac jones looks
weird in his uniform looks like nerdy
white man can't jump guy i mean that's
what it looks like it's tough i get that
fields has a rocket right arm but it can
be totally inaccurate at times he is a
great athlete you know where you go mac
jones is you know probably the most
accurate passer in the draft probably
the best decision maker in the draft you
know as far as moving in the pocket and
manipulating the pocket that way you
know it's him or zach wilson as far as
the best in the draft at that you know
pro ready done all the schemes
everything like that so it's all of that
added together that gives mac jones kind
of the eliteness of his game maybe not
one thing but it's a lot of real real
good that lets him play the position at
an elite level and i think that's where
people are at least in my opinion
misjudging him a little bit
trey lance thrown again today for scouts
that's pro day one pro day two
coming up all of these guys are having
multiple pro days because you can't do
private workouts this year atlanta
falcons reportedly setting the full
contingent chris
do you match trey lance with the falcons
or someone else i you know i and again
you know the falcons i just look at it
and i just feel like they're gonna stand
pat with matt ryan for another few years
you know again that's that's kind of the
way i envision it you know where he's at
in his career like we talked a little
last week about this mike he's got i
would think at least two or three at
least at least two or three really
quality years there to play like high
level football and he fits within the
offense of which arthur smith just ran
with ryan tannehill and tennessee that's
where i just think it matches so no with
trey lands i think the team i'm gonna
match him with as we sit here right now
at least you know 10 days out from the
draft the new england patriots that's
where i'm going to put trey lance
i i could totally see him on the board
around eight or nine in new england
making a move to go up and get him i
think it's a perfect spot the team's
built to kind of play that type of
football and he can sit behind cam
newton and kind of grow as a player hey
trey lance we don't know what he is as a
guy yet you know i mean he hasn't played
a lot of football as we talked about so
you know he he needs some time to sit
behind somebody and grow
here's the key phrase from peter king's
football morning in america as it
relates to the falcons and trey lance
what i'm hearing peter writes owner
arthur blank is fascinated by the
quarterbacks atop the draft thinking the
franchise might not be in such an
advantageous position to take one for
years but blank will not force a
decision of that i am sure peter and i
have debated that topic i think it was
10 days ago
where and how arthur blank will put his
thumb on the scale i continue to believe
that one of the billionaire privileges
is you don't have to force a decision
there's a subtlety there's a nuance to
making what you want known and i
continue to believe 2008
falcons were leaning glenn dorsey with
the third overall pick remember him sure
arthur blank wanted matt ryan arthur
blank got matt ryan i don't think he
forced the pick he had a new regime then
new gm new head coach thomas dimitrov
mike smith didn't force anything but
what the art what the owner or the
arthur wants the owner or the arthur
yeah and i think he i think he wants one
of these quarterbacks and i think it's
going to be lance okay all right usually
you think they're going to go that i
mean they're they're of course have like
the keys to the draft right now sitting
there at number four you know they could
do that
or they could take a kyle pitts
uh somebody like that and add him to
julio and calvin ridley and and matt
ryan and you go oh watch out that
offense could be one of the best in
football i mean it'll be interesting
they certainly have some flexibility i
don't know
maybe if they got a feel that they could
trade down just a little bit of a ways
if there was somebody that wanted to get
to four for some other type of player
like a kyle pitts or maybe a penny
sewell or something like that maybe they
could trade down a few spots and still
get trey lance maybe that does happen i
don't know that's i'm i'm really
interested to see what atlanta does with
that pick for sure you're right you're
right they could trade that you know i'm
thinking they could trade down to a team
that wants a quarterback they could also
trade down to a team that wants sewable
yeah bengals can get him at five that's
another thing you can do right but
you're running the risk if you slide
down yes
trade lance may not be there and you may
get jumped by the patriots or someone
else right as lance is working his way
towards
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports